Speaker 1: There is more and more information
coming out about a black man who was awaiting
a kidney transplant who was beaten by hospital
security. The man has sadly died. But we are
going to tell you the story. Black man awaiting
kidney transplant, beaten by hospital security.
The daughter of a late black kidney patient
wants justice against the security guards who
attacked and wrongly detained him, according
to the Saint Louis Post-Dispatch. The shocking
incident begins with Huey Robinson heading back
to the Barnes-Jewish Hospital in Saint Louis
after staff told him he left his wallet there a
few days before. The patient, who had stage four
renal failure, got the good news. He was number
two in line for a possible kidney transplant.
He got his wallet. He went back to the
garage when he couldn't find his car.
So he goes to the front desk. He and even
a security asks a security guard for help
as he looks for his car. Apparently, this caught
the attention of other security guards who started
suspecting this guy is not here for medical
treatment. This guy is here looking to steal cars.
Guards approach Robinson. They grab his arm
and he then allegedly asks, What did I do?
One of the guards tackles him, and then it all
gets crazy and he gets the crap kicked out of him.
And subsequently he died. It's an insane
story. There is indeed surveillance footage
and in the surveillance footage you see
a number of security officers come over
and very quickly the physical altercation begins.
We don't know what was being said there. A third
security guard comes in. They've got him pinned
to the ground and chaos ensues quite quickly.
Chaos ensues quite quickly. And he was looking for
his car. He had just gotten the good news. He's
second in line for a kidney transplant. And this
is what happens. We don't have all of the answers
yet, I guess we would say the lawsuit alleges
that Huie cried out that the guards were hurting
him and at least one of the guards responded.
Good. According to the lawsuit, the guards then
forced Hughie into a pair of handcuffs. It's
all on video. You decide. The document says
that Robinson was taken to an interrogation room.
He was asked, What are you doing in the garage?
The lawsuit also claims an officer used his
forearm to smash Huey's head into the wall while
another threatened the kidney patient. If one of
my officers or WashU officer sees you back on this
property again, we're going to do this whole thing
again. They told them, because you ain't supposed
to be here. He had just been at the hospital for
four days for treatment. For kidney problems.
He was drugged and in a weakened state when
security allegedly beat him up. Then there was a
lawsuit for assault, battery, false imprisonment.
He later died from his illness and his daughter
wants justice. So there are people saying, well,
why are you even mentioning that it's a black man?
We're mentioning it because it's yet another one
of these stories where I'll tell you guys, if you
tell me it it was a it was a white guy looking
around and saying, hey, I'm looking for my car.
I just don't believe that three security guards
show up suspecting that the guy is looking to
steal cars. I just don't think so. I just
don't believe it. And I know that there's a
movement on the right that loves to say, Oh,
David, you're racist for seeing the racism.
No, I don't think so. I mean, when you see these
stories and it goes beyond anecdotal and it
becomes the trend, it becomes the way they go. And
we featured others. It no longer is anecdotal. And
so that's why the story is being described in
the way that it's being described. And sadly,
this man ultimately died not from getting beat
up, but from his illness. We'll see where the
lawsuit goes. If you look at the video, if
you read the story, if you look at the facts
and come to and understand it differently.
Let me know. I want to hear from you